[Music]
for years Joseph her sure has been
fastidiously building incredibly complex
machines to simplify his life they turn
newspaper pages for him they cut his
hair and they serve him cake I am Joseph
and I make useless machines of course
utility is in the eye of the beholder as
a strength but in an age of computer
graphics and slick video editing Joseph
single continuous shot videos of wacky
contraptions stand out for their
intricately kinetic lo-fi whimsy and is
delivered to my open mouth machines are
usually designed to be as efficient as
possible and to then go and make a
machine that's super inefficient and
playful there's something sort of
delightful and absurd about it
his creations have delighted millions on
his YouTube channel Josef's machines the
first machine I ever made was to pour a
cup of tea for my roommates and it would
take so long to rather the tea would be
cold so that doesn't really work but we
filmed it and I put on YouTube and that
was the one that went viral and that's
how I ended up with this as a career
machines often start with a small
personal irritation I hate always trying
to get the last bit of ketchup out of a
bottle so you know when the sauce gets
stuck at the bottom of the bottle
annoying right so that motivates me like
there's got to be a better way here we
go
and then I remain but one day thinking I
know if I attach it to a fan and then
it's been in the fan so I made a videos
of that perfect Joseph who grew up in
New Zealand was fascinated by
problem-solving machines from a young
age growing up I had no siblings and I
would spend hours and hours on the floor
of my room making contraptions and for
me that was the best way to spend a day
on my own solving problems making crazy
stuff happen I am so happy that as an
adult I still get to do that and I still
get to play every day
now he's working on his latest
contraption I'm making a lunchtime
feeding machine so that I can keep
working through lunch without taking a
break and get more done here's the plan
it starts with me doing work as per
normal on my computer and when I pull a
handle it triggers a ball that knocks a
Brussels sprout to start rolling and
that brussel sprout rolls into my mouth
and then that triggers a hotdog to swing
into my mouth
on a pendulum there's a bow and arrow
that shoots an asparagus spear into my
mouth and finally some soup on a train
cause down my throat and all of this
happens without me having to actually
move positions so that's very convenient
but actually making the machines not so
convenient
basically all the food items are the
worst things to work with they're just
terrible for mechanical repetitive
actions because they're all slightly
different and like as they dry out they
start to change like the bread just
dries out and it won't Bend properly and
then the hotdog
bounces out of it there's just a myriad
a whole lot of problems and I Shh I tell
myself this every time like don't work
with food again but then I do it I don't
know why why to make his absurd machines
Joseph starts with sketches to plan out
how they'll work in his tiny New York
City apartment this is me figuring out
the exact angles of the bowl of soup so
that when the clock ticks it'll lift it
directly into my mouth then it's time to
find all of the parts
this is where I buy all my materials and
I love upstairs so it's very convenient
I spend a lot of time foraging for
objects in the neighborhood very
time-consuming if I know I need a
certain cup to fit from here to there
I'll go to every 99-cent store on my
block of which is 12 so I find exactly
the perfect cup
sometimes I'll spend like a whole day
looking for one object even with the
right item it takes a lot of time to
perfect a machine and then I'll build
the thing and then it might take better
know a few hours and then I'll spend
days tasting it like that's the longest
part trial and error failure after
failure after failure some of those
failures are pretty epic the page turner
was quite stressful it boils water which
then steams and goes into a sponge and
the sponge gets heavier and so I thought
I'd be smart and used acetone instead of
water because it boils much more quickly
because no one likes to watch the water
boil and I tasted that out and of course
acid is very flammable and I didn't
really think that through and so it
caught fire and then the sponge caught
fire and exploded and then it was like
but sponge on fire everywhere and then
the whole machine caught fire
even without in Firdos getting a machine
to work with clockwork precision takes a
long time it usually takes me about a
month to make a machine it's a
time-consuming process but the payoff
well just watch for yourself
there's the tricky Brussels sprout
Joseph had to weigh each one to find the
best rolling vegetables
[Music]
ah here's the hot dog Joseph has to aim
the hot dog back to the magnet right
here
it's a bit of human choreography in the
midst of the machine
[Music]
[Applause]
finally the soup it's actually water
food colouring and a thickening agent
which joseph fiennes easier to drink
than real soup and after a hearty meal
it's back to the drawing board to come
up with the next marvelous machine
[Music]